yeah somebody asked jd what's your
favorite possession
and it was sad because it ended up being
his spelling bee trophy from like fifth
grade or something no he didn't say that
yeah it was sad it was like sixth grade
yeah his you know his like the best
possession yeah there it is
what age 11 that's that's exactly the
point
he peaked at like 11. i don't know i i
felt sad that
jd his favorite possession is still like
a
trophy from one like his childhood yeah
i mean sorry i don't know what to tell
you it's uh
that's my favorite possession jd claims
if there was a fire in his apartment his
spelling bee trophy is the first thing
he would grab
and then and then we were like well jd
would you sell us
like for a thousand bucks would you sell
us your spelling bee trophy
right now i would rather have the trophy
than a thousand more dollars than i have
right now
would you sell the trophy for five
thousand dollars
no anything below a hundred thousand
well
maybe it's like ninety nine thousand
nine hundred ninety
anything below that uh uh probably not
so essentially you have a hundred
thousand dollars worth of pride in that
if you want to put it like that sure i
guess oh my god hey jd
how do you spell uh pathetic
okay if your wife was kind of like
cleaning up the apartment and
accidentally broke your trophy
would you freak out uh
i might not be thrilled uh but uh
i i think i would i think i would like
pieces together or i would at least keep
you know you really can't think of a
possession in your adult life that would
supersede that fourth grade spelling bee
i mean
stuff that well listen they're obviously
they're like things
uh uh from family and my wife or
whatever
okay we'll name one i can't think of one
think of one right now uh what happened
to your uh spoon collection where is
that
well actually i pulled some out the
other day because someone was asking
they're looking very nasty
i don't know if i want to show them
right now what do you show me your three
top spoons
i actually don't know where so there was
this one from universal studios that i
got
with the uh looks like goofy oh actually
there's two in here
oh good for you that's a goofy spot wow
maybe there's something valuable there
there's a goofy spoon
and then uh universal studios
oh my god good lord how you doing jd
puppet you
uh you have a choice by the way if there
was a fire
in my apartment and there's a choice
between my wife
and my trophy hmm
i'll get back to you all right be
ridiculous puppy
well yeah
i like when the puppet talks to jd
directly yeah
you